This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's summertime in New York. The year is 1902. And the second and Wilhelm's printing company in Brooklyn has a problem. That's producer Emmett that's Gerald. They're trying to print the popular humor magazine, Judge. And it's really hot and there's a lot of humidity and they're having trouble getting the inks to set properly on the page.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。纽约的夏天，1902年。布鲁克林的威廉印刷公司遇到了一个难题。那是制片人埃米特·杰拉德。他们正试图印刷一本名为《法官》的流行幽默杂志。当时天气非常炎热，湿度很高，他们很难让油墨在纸张上正常定型。
This is writer Steven Johnson, author of the book, How We Got To Now. He says the problem isn't so much the heat, but the moisture in the air, which was warping the paper and throwing the print out of alignment. And so they hire a young, enterprising engineer by the name of Willis Carrier to solve this problem
这位是作家史蒂文·约翰逊，他是《我们是如何走到今天的》一书的作者。他说，问题不在于热，而在于空气中的水分，这导致纸张变形，印刷错位。于是，他们聘请了一位年轻且富有进取心的工程师，名叫威利斯·开利来解决这个问题。
and basically pull the moisture out of the air inside the printing plant. And Carrier develops a system that pumps air over cold metal coils. And it works. It pulls the moisture out of the air and the magazines are printed more efficiently and the inks don't run. But it has a side effect of of as it's pulling the moisture out of the air, it also makes the air cooler. And so of course, everybody wants to have lunch in the room with his new machine.
基本上就是把印刷厂内的空气水分抽走。开利开发了一种系统，将空气吹过冷的金属盘管。这招奏效了。它抽走了空气中的水分，杂志印刷得更高效，油墨也不会晕染。但它有一个副作用，在抽走水分的同时，空气也变凉了。于是，当然，每个人都想在有他那台新机器的房间里吃午饭。
I've heard he's like, well, this is so nice of you. I would have bring my sandwich and sit next to the printing press because it's the air is so much more pleasant. Carrier had invented air conditioning. And he began to think that maybe his new technology could do more than just keep paper dry. Maybe it's something that could actually be harnessed in the service of just human comfort. He first installs his system in textile factories, tobacco plants, and other industrial workplaces
我听说他当时就像是，好吧，你们真是太客气了。我会带上我的三明治坐在印刷机旁边，因为那里的空气实在太舒服了。开利发明了空调。他开始思考，也许他的新技术不仅仅能保持纸张干燥。也许它能被用于服务人类的舒适感。他首先将他的系统安装在纺织厂、烟草厂和其他工业工作场所。
that required low humidity levels. But his invention really catches on in a very different kind of place. So before air conditioning, the last place you would want to go in the summer was to crowd into a movie theater with a thousand other human beings on a day when it was 95 degrees out, right? That would just be completely intolerable. And movie theaters really struggled to sell tickets during the summer months. So, Carrier approaches a bunch of theater owners all around the country with an idea.
这些地方需要低湿度环境。但他的发明在一种截然不同的地方真正流行了起来。在空调出现之前，夏天你最不想去的地方就是挤进一家电影院，和一千个人待在一起，那天外面有95华氏度（约35摄氏度），对吧？那简直完全无法忍受。电影院在夏季确实很难卖出票。于是，开利带着一个想法接触了全国各地的影院老板。
I'll install a new machine that turns your place of business into a crisp, cool, oasis. It won't be cheap, but you'll make up for the cost in summer ticket sales. And that's exactly what happened. Theater owners advertised their chilled air, and people came out to air-conditioned theaters in droves. Yes, you lucky people just sit back for a moment, relax, and notice the delight for the clean, cool, and refreshing atmosphere of this scientifically air-conditioned theater. Great, isn't it? This advertisement from the 1940s shows a bunch of theater goers wearing fur parkas and icicles dripping from the ceiling.
我会安装一台新机器，把你的营业场所变成一个清爽凉快的绿洲。这不便宜，但你会在夏季的票房收入中赚回成本。事实也确实如此。影院老板们宣传他们凉爽的空气，人们成群结队地来到有空调的电影院。是的，你们这些幸运的人，请坐下来放松一下，感受一下这个科学空调影院带来的干净、凉爽和清新的氛围。很棒，不是吗？这段1940年代的广告展示了一群电影观众穿着皮大衣，天花板上挂着冰柱。
Suddenly, movies went from being the last place you'd want to be on a summer day to being actually one of the nicest places to be. And this whole tradition of having these big movies that come out in the summer became possible. The summer blockbuster was born. But air conditioning would do a lot more than just create the summer blockbuster. It would dramatically change where people in the United States lived and the design of our buildings and homes. But the air conditioning revolution didn't happen all at once. Before World War II, a few wealthy elites had air conditioning systems installed in their
突然间，电影院从夏天最不想去的地方变成了最舒适的地方之一。这种在夏天上映大片的传统也因此成为可能。暑期大片诞生了。但空调的作用远不止创造暑期大片。它极大地改变了美国人的居住地以及我们的建筑和房屋设计。但空调革命并非一蹴而就。二战前，少数富有的精英在他们的
mansions, but mechanically chilled air was still seen as a luxury, something to be enjoyed at the theater, but certainly not in your own home. But Willis Carrier wanted to change that. In a 1929 speech, he said, air conditioning and cooling for summer may become a necessity rather than a luxury. And we will look upon present times as marking the end of that dark age in which there was but relatively little cooling for human comfort. The big transformation for air conditioning that really arrives after World War II is like
豪宅中安装了空调系统，但机械制冷空气仍被视为一种奢侈品，是可以在剧院享受的东西，但绝不是在自己家里。但威利斯·开利想改变这一点。在1929年的一次演讲中，他说，夏季的空调和制冷可能会成为一种必需品，而不是奢侈品。我们将把现在视为那个黑暗时代的终结，那时几乎没有什么制冷设备来提供人类的舒适感。空调的重大变革真正到来是在二战之后，就像
so many stories of technology really a story about miniaturization of taking something that was really big and shrinking it down. Early AC systems were massive, way too big for an individual home. But by the late 1940s, carrier and other companies were selling air conditioners that could fit in your window. But they were expensive. And it wasn't clear at first that people would buy them. I think advertising played a huge role in the increased use of air conditioning in the
许多技术故事一样，这实际上是一个关于小型化的故事，即把非常大的东西缩小。早期的空调系统非常庞大，对于个人家庭来说太大了。但到了1940年代末，开利和其他公司开始销售可以安装在窗户上的空调。但它们很贵。起初并不清楚人们是否会购买。我认为广告在空调的使用增加方面发挥了巨大作用。
residential sector. And what's really interesting is that the advertising really played on the role of women and their social status. This is Gail Breager. She is an architecture professor at the UC Berkeley College of Environmental Design and an expert on thermal comfort. So if you look at the advertising in the 1950s, a lot of them showed women dressed like beaver cleavers mom with the pearls and the gloved hands and dressed well, and it was really trying
在住宅领域。真正有趣的是，广告确实利用了女性的角色和社会地位。这位是盖尔·布雷格。她是加州大学伯克利分校环境设计学院的建筑学教授，也是热舒适度方面的专家。所以如果你看看1950年代的广告，很多广告展示的女性穿着像《天才老爸俏妈》里的妈妈，戴着珍珠项链，戴着手套，打扮得体，这确实是在试图
to associate social status with air conditioning. That if you have air conditioning, you can live this life of leisure, and you wouldn't have to sweat with the toil of housework. These ads also played on the idea that with air conditioning, homeowners could take control over nature. The desert, 110 by day, cool enough to need heat the same night. Here's an air conditioning commercial from the early 1960s that takes place in Palm Springs. The maximum test for air conditioning, what system works best? Let's ask the owner of this desert show place Miss Dina Shore. Hi, with my year-round
将社会地位与空调联系起来。如果你有空调，你就能过上这种悠闲的生活，不必为家务劳作而汗流浃背。这些广告还利用了这样一个观点：有了空调，房主就能掌控自然。沙漠，白天110华氏度（约43摄氏度），晚上凉爽到需要供暖。这是一则1960年代初在棕榈泉拍摄的空调广告。空调的终极考验，什么系统效果最好？让我们问问这个沙漠豪宅的主人，迪娜·肖尔小姐。嗨，有了我的全年
gas air conditioning by Arclad, I just touched the thermostat for delightful cooling or comfortable heat in every room. Humanity controlled, dust and pollen filtered. My indoor climate is always perfect. It was very compelling to advertising and I think that really played on people adopting air conditioning more into the home. In 1960, 13% of homes in the United States had AC. By 1980, it was up to 55%.
Arclad燃气空调，我只需触碰恒温器，每个房间都能享受令人愉悦的凉爽或舒适的暖气。湿度受控，灰尘和花粉被过滤。我的室内气候总是完美的。这广告非常有说服力，我认为这确实促使人们更多地在家里使用空调。1960年，美国13%的家庭拥有空调。到1980年，这一比例上升到了55%。
Today is close to 90%. In just a few decades, air conditioning went from luxury to necessity, just as Willis Carrier predicted. The ubiquity of AC has had a serious impact on how and maybe most profoundly where we live. All of a sudden, there are parts of the United States that had historically been really unpleasant
今天接近90%。在短短几十年内，空调从奢侈品变成了必需品，正如威利斯·开利所预言的那样。空调的普及对我们的生活方式，或许最深刻的是对我们的居住地产生了严重的影响。突然之间，美国有一些地区在历史上一直非常不适宜
to live in, particularly during the summer months, that suddenly because of these home air conditioning units are now actually delightful places to live. The population of states like Arizona and Florida exploded. So in that period, after the introduction of home air conditioning, there is this really arguably one of the largest migrations of people in the history of the United States, moving from the north to the south to what we now call the the sun belt. If you could air condition your way through the summer, then living in the middle of a desert or a humid swamp was no big deal. In just 10 years Tucson went from 45,000 people to 210,000 people. In the same decade, Houston almost doubled its population.
居住，特别是在夏季，现在因为这些家用空调机，实际上变成了令人愉悦的居住地。亚利桑那州和佛罗里达州等州的人口激增。因此，在引入家用空调后的那段时间里，这可以说是美国历史上最大规模的人口迁移之一，从北方迁移到南方，迁移到我们现在所说的“阳光地带”。如果你能通过空调度过夏天，那么住在沙漠或潮湿的沼泽中间就没什么大不了的。在短短10年内，图森的人口从4.5万增加到21万。在同一个十年里，休斯顿的人口几乎翻了一番。
And Florida during, you know, kind of the 1920s had only a million people living there. But 50 years later, there were nearly 7 million people in Florida. This mass migration was so significant, it changed the political map. Increased populations meant states like Florida got more votes in the electoral college. And since a lot of these new southward migrants were conservative retirees, they tended to vote Republican. You begin to build this kind of Republican sunbelt coalition
而佛罗里达在1920年代只有一百万人居住。但50年后，佛罗里达有近700万人。这种大规模迁移意义重大，它改变了政治版图。人口增加意味着佛罗里达等州在选举人团中获得了更多选票。由于许多这些向南迁移的新移民是保守派退休人员，他们倾向于投票给共和党。你开始建立这种共和党阳光地带联盟
that didn't exist before. And that coalition is really crucial to Reagan's successful bid for the presidency in 1980. There were obviously a lot of different factors that led to Reagan's election. But I think that had air conditioning not been invented. Reagan might still have gotten elected, but he would have required a different political coalition to make it possible. The population of the Sun Belt boomed with the advent of air conditioning. But it's not as if no one lived in these places before AC. Those who did had developed lots of strategies to beat the heat,
这是以前不存在的。而那个联盟对里根在1980年成功竞选总统至关重要。显然，导致里根当选的因素有很多。但我认为，如果空调没有被发明出来，里根可能仍然会当选，但他需要一个不同的政治联盟才能实现。阳光地带的人口随着空调的出现而激增。但这并不是说在空调出现之前没有人住在这些地方。那些住在那里的人已经发展出了许多应对高温的策略，
including forms of vernacular architecture that were carefully attuned to the climate. Vernacular refers to traditional architecture that develops in a particular place and it's often driven by local environmental conditions. So if you look at traditional buildings and hot climates, so many of the elements are going to be different if you're in a hot, drier, hot humid climate. In the desert southwest, houses were traditionally built with hefty materials like a doby and stone that can absorb heat. You're soaking up the heat during the day, keeping it from getting inside, and then releasing it to the colder air at night.
包括精心适应气候的本土建筑形式。本土建筑是指在特定地区发展起来的传统建筑，通常由当地环境条件驱动。所以如果你看看炎热气候下的传统建筑，如果你处于炎热干燥或炎热潮湿的气候中，许多元素都会有所不同。在沙漠西南部，房屋传统上是用土坯和石头等厚重的材料建造的，可以吸收热量。白天吸收热量，防止热量进入室内，然后在晚上将其释放到较冷的空气中。
Homes in the southwest also tended to have flat roofs and small windows that could be closed up during the day and opened at night to let the cool air in. However, in the humid southeast, the vernacular architecture tried to maximize shade and air movement. There were screened in sleeping porches, breezeways between rooms, and cupolas in the roof to draw cool air up through the house. You tend to have much larger windows, much larger, operable windows, so the entire facade could be opened up. You might have much larger shaded porches and balconies, so there's a lot of outdoor living. And so you can look at the architecture and it says something about the place. Andaman Coldair freed architects from the challenge of designing a home that was uniquely suited to the climate around it. And as we got more mechanical systems
西南地区的房屋也倾向于有平屋顶和小窗户，白天可以关闭，晚上打开以让凉爽的空气进入。然而，在潮湿的东南部，本土建筑试图最大限度地利用遮阳和空气流动。有带纱窗的睡眠门廊、房间之间的通风廊，以及屋顶上的圆顶，将凉爽的空气向上吸入整个房子。你往往会有更大的窗户，更大的可操作窗户，这样整个立面都可以打开。你可能会有更大的遮阳门廊和阳台，所以有很多户外生活。所以你可以看看建筑，它说明了一些关于这个地方的事情。而空调将建筑师从设计独特适应周围气候的房屋的挑战中解放了出来。随着我们拥有了更多的机械系统
and the power to heat and cool buildings through mechanical systems, I think architects started relinquishing control of environmental conditioning to the engineers. Air conditioning systems were expensive, but home builders made up for the cost by cutting down on passive cooling features. And little by little, the local architectural traditions rooted in the climate
以及通过机械系统加热和冷却建筑的能力，我认为建筑师开始将环境调节的控制权让给了工程师。空调系统很贵，但房屋建筑商通过减少被动冷却功能来弥补成本。一点一点地，植根于气候的当地建筑传统
gave way to tightly sealed mass produced tract homes. So a house in the southwest might look the same as a house in New Orleans, which might look the same as a house in Minnesota. And whether you were in a hot humid, hot, dry, or cold climate, I think architecture really lost a sense of place. The rise of track housing had to do with more than just air conditioning. It was influenced by the development of the highway system and the suburbanization of American life.
让位于密封严密的批量生产的住宅区。所以西南地区的房子可能看起来和新奥尔良的房子一样，可能和明尼苏达州的房子一样。无论你是在炎热潮湿、炎热干燥还是寒冷的气候中，我认为建筑确实失去了地方感。住宅区的发展不仅仅与空调有关。它受到高速公路系统发展和美国生活郊区化的影响。
But AC enabled the mass production of affordable homes that could exist in many different climate zones. Air conditioning didn't just change residential architecture. It revolutionized the design of skyscrapers, schools, and office buildings. Before air conditioning, the only source of cool air was the outdoors. And so, offices usually had high ceilings and lots of windows that people could open. And so, all offices had at least one wall that was exposed to the perimeter. You might have court guards in the center of buildings so that even the spaces that weren't on the street would have access to the air and light on the inside.
但空调实现了可以在许多不同气候区存在的经济适用房的批量生产。空调不仅改变了住宅建筑。它彻底改变了摩天大楼、学校和办公楼的设计。在空调出现之前，凉爽空气的唯一来源是户外。因此，办公室通常有高高的天花板和许多人们可以打开的窗户。因此，所有办公室至少有一面墙暴露在周边。你可能会在建筑中心有庭院，这样即使是不在街道上的空间也能获得内部的空气和光线。
If you look at the floor plans of many mid-rise buildings from the early 20th century, they often have these thin, irregular shapes. They looked like letters when viewed from above. So we sometimes call them alphabet buildings because they'd be in the shape of E, an H, an I, and O. But with air conditioning buildings could fill up the entire lot with offices deep inside the core of the building, nowhere near a window. Air conditioning also changed facade design before AC. They addressed the issue of too much sun by providing appropriate shading or awnings.
如果你看看20世纪初许多中层建筑的平面图，它们通常有这些细长、不规则的形状。从上方看，它们看起来像字母。所以我们有时称它们为字母建筑，因为它们呈E、H、I和O形。但有了空调，建筑可以填满整个地块，办公室位于建筑核心深处，远离窗户。空调也改变了立面设计。在空调出现之前，他们通过提供适当的遮阳或遮阳篷来解决阳光过多的问题。
Fasads were carefully designed to avoid too much sun coming into a space. This is Lisa Hechung, an architect who spent her career studying light in architecture. When we discovered air conditioning, all of a sudden we could have these continuous glass facades because we had solved the problem with power conditioning instead of appropriate facade design or building design. It was just brute force power. Air conditioning our way out of all of these design issues.
立面经过精心设计，以避免过多的阳光进入空间。这位是丽莎·赫崇，一位毕生致力于研究建筑光线的建筑师。当我们发现空调时，突然之间我们可以拥有这些连续的玻璃幕墙，因为我们通过动力调节解决了问题，而不是通过适当的立面设计或建筑设计。这只是蛮力。用空调来解决所有这些设计问题。
Now this wasn't all a bad thing. Many modern architects were happy to see the problem of thermal comfort to the engineers. It meant they could focus on aesthetics. And so it was incredibly empowering to architects to be able to relinquish that control. With AC, they were free to design the sleek, hermetically sealed glass towers
现在这并不全是坏事。许多现代建筑师很高兴看到热舒适问题交给了工程师。这意味着他们可以专注于美学。因此，能够放弃这种控制权对建筑师来说是非常赋权的。有了空调，他们可以自由设计时尚、密封的玻璃塔
that became hallmarks of modernism. It's safe to say that without air conditioning, we would not have many of the great modernist buildings at the 20th century. Oh, absolutely not. But as a consequence, the modern built environment in the United States is now totally dependent on air conditioning.
这成为了现代主义的标志。可以肯定地说，如果没有空调，我们就不会有许多20世纪伟大的现代主义建筑。哦，绝对不会。但结果是，美国现代建筑环境现在完全依赖于空调。
A lot of our buildings would be uninhabitable in the summer without AC. And all that cool air requires a lot of power. We now use as much electricity for air conditioning as we used for all purposes in 1955. This is Stan Cox, author of the book, Losing Our Cool. He says AC consumption has continued to rise. From 1993 to 2005, the amount of electricity used for air conditioning doubled nationwide. One of the big reasons was that houses were getting larger, and virtually all of those newly constructed ones were getting central air installed in them.
如果没有空调，我们的许多建筑在夏天将无法居住。而所有这些凉爽的空气需要大量的电力。我们现在用于空调的电力与1955年我们用于所有目的的电力一样多。这位是斯坦·考克斯，《失去冷静》一书的作者。他说空调消耗量持续上升。从1993年到2005年，全国用于空调的电量翻了一番。一个主要原因是房屋越来越大，几乎所有新建的房屋都安装了中央空调。
The larger the home, the more space needs to be filled with cool air. It's crazy to think about it. To me, on a hot day here in Kansas, there are 3,000 square foot houses being kept at 70 degrees all day long, and all the occupants are off at work in school. And so it's not cooling a human being at all. And all that air conditioning might be keeping our
房子越大，需要填充凉爽空气的空间就越多。想到这一点真是太疯狂了。对我来说，在堪萨斯州炎热的一天，有3000平方英尺（约278平方米）的房子整天保持在70华氏度（约21摄氏度），而所有居住者都在工作和上学。所以它根本没有冷却人类。而所有这些空调可能正在保持我们的
building school but it's making the outside world hotter. The additional greenhouse emissions from air conditioning in the United States add up to about 500 million tons of CO2 equivalent per year. He says that's more than the entire construction industry, including the production of materials like concrete. So it's a very significant amount. In fact, in 2010, when Stan Cox wrote his book, he says the US was using as much energy for air conditioning
建筑凉爽，但它正在使外部世界变得更热。美国空调产生的额外温室气体排放量每年总计约5亿吨二氧化碳当量。他说这比整个建筑行业还要多，包括混凝土等材料的生产。所以这是一个非常可观的数量。事实上，在2010年，当斯坦·考克斯写他的书时，他说美国用于空调的能源
as the entire continent of Africa was using as much energy for air conditioning as the entire continent of Africa was using for all purposes. And all of these structures that require massive amounts of energy to keep cool, we've been exporting them to the rest of the world, including really hot places like Dubai. What America has been fantastic with across the board in terms of design and architecture is making a brand and exporting it. However, a lot of that architecture is non-responsive to the conditions of the Middle East. This is Manit Rustogi, an Indian architect and co-founder of the firm Morphogenesis,
和整个非洲大陆用于所有目的的能源一样多。而所有这些需要大量能源来保持凉爽的结构，我们一直在将它们出口到世界其他地方，包括像迪拜这样非常炎热的地方。美国在设计和建筑方面一直非常出色的是打造品牌并将其出口。然而，很多建筑对中东的条件没有反应。这位是马尼特·鲁斯托吉，一位印度建筑师，也是Morphogenesis公司的联合创始人，
based in New Delhi. Rustogi says that a lot of the buildings in Indian cities today look like they could be buildings in any other city around the world. So you'll end up class towers that require a lot of air conditioning. But India also has a long history of vernacular architecture designed to keep people cool. And Rastogi started looking back at some of these old buildings and thought, Wait a minute. We used to do this really well, not so long back. Why are we
总部位于新德里。鲁斯托吉说，今天印度城市的许多建筑看起来就像世界各地任何其他城市的建筑。所以你最终会得到需要大量空调的玻璃塔。但印度也有悠久的本土建筑历史，旨在保持人们凉爽。而拉托吉开始回顾一些这些古老的建筑，心想，等一下。不久前我们还做得很好。为什么我们
building differently today? Rostogi has devoted his career to designing functional modern buildings that borrow passive cooling techniques from traditional Indian architecture and require very little if any air conditioning, like his design for the Pearl Academy of Fashion. So the pearl Academy of Fashion is on the outskirts of Jaipur, which is essentially a desert climate. When Rastogi started working on the Pearl Academy, he looked at old Indian buildings in hot, dry climates for inspiration.
今天建造的方式不同了？罗斯托吉致力于设计功能性的现代建筑，借鉴传统印度建筑的被动冷却技术，几乎不需要空调，比如他为珍珠时尚学院所做的设计。所以珍珠时尚学院位于斋浦尔郊区，本质上是沙漠气候。当罗斯托吉开始在珍珠学院工作时，他从炎热干燥气候下的古老印度建筑中寻找灵感。
He studied old forts and palaces to see how they stayed cool. And he was particularly impressed by a feature called the Bowley. Bowley, yes, the Bowley, the step well. Bowley's are traditional Indian step wells found in many old palaces. They're basically pools of water dug deep into the ground beneath the building and surrounded on all sides by descending steps, intricately carved from stone. The cool temperatures from underground combine with the evaporative cooling of the water to lower the temperature in the palace.
他研究了古老的堡垒和宫殿，看看它们是如何保持凉爽的。他特别对一种叫做“Bowley”的功能印象深刻。Bowley，是的，Bowley，阶梯井。Bowley是传统的印度阶梯井，在许多古老的宫殿中都能找到。它们基本上是深挖在建筑下方地下的水池，四周环绕着从石头上精心雕刻而成的下降台阶。地下的凉爽温度与水的蒸发冷却相结合，降低了宫殿的温度。
Rostogi decided to put a modern take on this ancient architectural feature in his building. So we created a bowel, a step well, across the entire site. We dug three meters down into the ground and we recycled all the water into that step build condition and allowed for evaporative cooling to come off and cool the side down. The top of the building is insulated using earthenware pots. And the sides of the building we put locally manufactured jalees that keep the sun out but let the light in.
罗斯托吉决定在他的建筑中对这一古老的建筑特色进行现代诠释。所以我们创造了一个Bowley，一个阶梯井，横跨整个场地。我们向下挖掘了三米，并将所有水循环到那个阶梯井条件中，允许蒸发冷却散发出来并冷却场地。建筑顶部使用陶罐进行隔热。在建筑侧面，我们放置了当地制造的Jalees（镂空屏风），既能遮挡阳光又能让光线进入。
The jalee is a traditional Indian architectural feature. It's basically a lattice screen filled with all these tiny holes that let in diffuse sunlight without too much heat. And we put all that together. And when the project finished, we were getting temperatures of 29 degrees, when the outside temperature was 46 degrees without air conditioning.
Jalee是一种传统的印度建筑特色。它基本上是一个充满所有这些微小孔洞的格子屏风，在没有太多热量的情况下让漫射阳光进入。我们把所有这些放在一起。当项目完成时，当外部温度为46摄氏度时，我们内部的温度达到了29摄氏度，而且没有空调。
In Fahrenheit, that's 84 degrees inside the building, when it was 115 degrees outside. It's still hot, but doable. For an office building, that doesn't actually sound all doable, to me, that sounds way too hot. Yeah, I kind of think so too, but Rostogi says that for someone used to living in Gipore, India, it's a pretty pleasant temperature. He says thermal comfort is relative. Standards for what constitutes thermal comfort is where I think the whole problem sort of sits. Architects and engineers around the world use thermal comfort. It's where I think the whole problem sort of sets. Architects and engineers around the world
华氏度的话，那是84华氏度，而外面是115华氏度。还是很热，但可以接受。对于办公楼来说，这听起来并不太可行，对我来说，这听起来太热了。是的，我也这么认为，但罗斯托吉说，对于习惯住在印度斋浦尔的人来说，这是一个相当舒适的温度。他说热舒适度是相对的。关于什么是热舒适度的标准，我认为整个问题就出在这里。世界各地的建筑师和工程师使用热舒适度。我认为整个问题就出在这里。世界各地的建筑师和工程师
use thermal comfort standards set by the American society of heating, refrigerating, and air conditioning engineers. Historically, these standards have dictated a relatively narrow temperature window that all buildings should be kept at. The only way to be certain that a building can meet that standard all year long
使用美国供暖、制冷和空调工程师协会设定的热舒适标准。从历史上看，这些标准规定了一个相对狭窄的温度范围，所有建筑都应该保持在这个范围内。确保建筑全年都能达到该标准的唯一方法
is with lots of air conditioning and heating. But if you've ever worked in an office, you know that some people are always hot, shriek, while others, Katie, are always cold. You will never achieve a static environment where 100% of the people are happy. This is architect Lisa Hesschung again. There's a huge amount of individual variation in what people experience and what they prefer. Our thermal preferences vary based on age and sex and the climate that we're used to. But the whole goal of conditioning buildings is to create a static indoor climate, one
就是使用大量的空调和供暖。但如果你在办公室工作过，你就知道有些人总是很热，而有些人总是很冷。你永远无法实现一个让100%的人都满意的静态环境。这位又是建筑师丽莎·赫崇。人们的体验和偏好存在巨大的个体差异。我们的热偏好因年龄、性别和我们习惯的气候而异。但调节建筑的全部目标是创造一个静态的室内气候，一个
temperature that will hopefully be the least unpleasant to the most number of people. Gail Breger calls this thermal monotony. She and her team at UC Berkeley have developed new thermal comfort standards that allow for a wider range of temperatures within buildings. Breger doesn't want to get rid of air conditioning altogether, but she thinks we can be more intentional about when and where we use it.
温度，希望对最多的人来说是最不令人不快的。盖尔·布雷格称之为“热单调”。她和她在加州大学伯克利分校的团队开发了新的热舒适标准，允许建筑内有更广泛的温度范围。布雷格并不想完全摆脱空调，但她认为我们可以更有意识地决定何时何地使用它。
Our environmental conditioning systems think about heating and cooling spaces rather than heating and cooling people. Rager says we don't need to heat and cool corridors to the same degree as the parts of an office where people spend most of their day. And she says we can save enormous amounts of energy by letting the temperatures and buildings fluctuate over a wider range and giving people more tools to heat and cool themselves. To do that, it's going to take a combination of high and low tech approaches.
我们的环境调节系统考虑的是加热和冷却空间，而不是加热和冷却人。布雷格说，我们不需要将走廊加热和冷却到与人们一天中大部分时间所在的办公室部分相同的程度。她说，我们可以通过让建筑内的温度在更广泛的范围内波动，并给人们更多的工具来加热和冷却自己，从而节省大量的能源。要做到这一点，需要结合高科技和低科技的方法。
A window that you can open right by your desk is a great personal cooling device. A sweater is a pretty good personal heating device. But breaker energy are also developing low energy desk fans, foot warmers. And the chair I'm sitting in right now, you might see these dials. This is a heated and cool chair. And this to me is the ultimate form of a personal comfort system, we call it, PCS, because we're all gonna feel something different.
你办公桌旁可以打开的窗户是一个很棒的个人冷却设备。毛衣是一个很好的个人加热设备。但布雷格也在开发低能耗的桌面风扇、暖脚器。还有我现在坐的这把椅子，你可能会看到这些刻度盘。这是一把加热和冷却椅。对我来说，这是个人舒适系统的终极形式，我们称之为PCS，因为我们每个人都会有不同的感觉。
And we could be sitting in the same environment, but one person may be feeling warm, one person may be feeling cool. And would you like to sit in this chair? Okay, we're gonna switch places. Okay, let's switch places. Okay. Sit in that chair.
我们可以坐在同一个环境中，但一个人可能会感到温暖，一个人可能会感到凉爽。你想坐在这把椅子上吗？好的，我们要换个位置。好的，让我们换个位置。好的。坐在那把椅子上。
You're gonna sit in it for a while and it's gonna feel really warm. People are getting more and more used to heated seats in our cars. So why not have heated and cooled seats in our office? So now I'm going to reach over and turn it to cooling. Okay. And you should feel that pretty good. Oh wow. Yeah. Wow. It's blowing air across your back and your seat. Oh it's so nice. I have sometimes had my back aches all how they heated back. Reducing our reliance on air conditioning
你会坐一会儿，它会感觉非常温暖。人们越来越习惯我们车里的加热座椅。那么为什么不在我们的办公室里安装加热和冷却座椅呢？所以现在我要伸手把它调到冷却。好的。你应该感觉很不错。哦，哇。是的。哇。它正在吹过你的背部和座位。哦，太好了。我有时背痛，加热背部感觉真好。减少我们对空调的依赖
is often framed as a loss, giving up comfort. But neither Gail Breger, more or less a Hesheng, see it that way. Back in the 70s, Hesheng wrote this beautiful little book called Thermal Delight in Architecture. And in it, she argues that we should think about a perception of temperature as a sense. Just like any other sense, temperature can cause us discomfort, but it can also give us a lot of pleasure or delight, the feeling of a warm
通常被描述为一种损失，放弃舒适。但盖尔·布雷格和丽莎·赫崇都不这么认为。早在70年代，赫崇写了一本名为《建筑中的热愉悦》的美丽小书。在书中，她认为我们应该把对温度的感知视为一种感官。就像任何其他感官一样，温度会导致我们不适，但它也可以给我们带来很多快乐或愉悦，冬天温暖的
fire in the winter, or a cool breeze on a hot summer night, or sliding back into your heated chair after a trip outside. She wrote about how thermal experience could enrich our architectural design and a new dimension. And it requires change. It turns out that physiologically, the only way we can have that moment is to actually have some kind of variability in our lives. Gail Breger has done studies on thermal comfort in buildings around the world. And she's found that people actually prefer naturally ventilated buildings where they can open windows and feel a little bit of control over their own temperature.
火，或者炎热夏夜的凉风，或者在外面走了一圈后滑回你加热的椅子里。她写了热体验如何以一个新的维度丰富我们的建筑设计。这需要改变。事实证明，从生理上讲，我们能够拥有那一刻的唯一方法是让我们的生活中确实有某种变异性。盖尔·布雷格对世界各地建筑中的热舒适度进行了研究。她发现人们实际上更喜欢自然通风的建筑，在那里他们可以打开窗户，对自己温度的控制感稍强一些。
Turns out that not only do you tolerate, but you actually prefer a wider set of conditions. Today, the average person spends about 90% of their time indoors. And Gail Breger doesn't think we should live so much of our lives and thermal monotony. Imagine life if we ate the same foods every day, right? If we didn't have changing weather and everything was the same all of the time. It would be terrible, but that's essentially
事实证明，你不仅能忍受，而且实际上更喜欢更广泛的条件。今天，普通人大约90%的时间都在室内。盖尔·布雷格不认为我们应该在热单调中度过这么多生活。想象一下，如果我们每天吃同样的食物，对吧？如果我们没有变化的天气，一切总是相同的。那会很糟糕，但这本质上就是
what we're trying to do in our buildings. Towards the end of my conversation with Gail, I reluctantly offer to give her chair back. Should we switch seats? Get you back in here. Give me back. Yeah, I don't want to deprive you of thermal the light for the rest of this interview.
我们在建筑中试图做的事情。在我和盖尔谈话快结束时，我不情愿地提出把椅子还给她。我们应该换座位吗？让你回到这里。还给我。是的，我不想在这次采访的剩余时间里剥夺你的热愉悦。
It's quite nice, isn't it? It really is. I was not expecting that to be as simple. It's so horrible. I like my chair quite a bit. You should. I like my chair quite a bit. You should. Special thanks to architects Ron Hossie and Steve Bedan, who also spoke to us for this piece.
这很不错，不是吗？确实如此。我没想到它会这么简单。太可怕了。我很喜欢我的椅子。你应该喜欢。我很喜欢我的椅子。你应该喜欢。特别感谢建筑师罗恩·霍西和史蒂夫·贝丹，他们也为这篇文章接受了我们的采访。
Since a bunch of you have asked, Kurt and I are going to talk about terrifying incoming missile false alarms in Hawaii right after this. So a few months ago, thanks in part to increased tensions with North Korea, the Hawaii Emergency Management Agency started doing ballistic missile attack drills. But the other day, someone was initiating a test alert and apparently chose the wrong option from a list of very confusing options So Kurt is here to give us the details So at 807 in the morning a message went out to cell phones in Hawaii ballistic missile threat inbound to Hawaii seek immediate shelter. This is not a drill
既然你们很多人都问了，我和库尔特将在之后讨论夏威夷令人恐惧的导弹虚假警报。几个月前，部分由于与朝鲜的紧张局势加剧，夏威夷紧急事务管理局开始进行弹道导弹袭击演习。但前几天，有人在启动测试警报时，显然从一长串非常令人困惑的选项中选择了错误的选项。所以库尔特在这里给我们详细介绍。所以早上8点07分，夏威夷的手机收到了一条消息：弹道导弹威胁即将到达夏威夷，立即寻求庇护。这不是演习。
inbound to Hawaii, seek immediate shelter. This is not a drill. Within a few minutes, officials knew it was a false alarm and started doing damage control, but natural stand-down alert wasn't issued until 8.45, more than half an hour after it all began. Okay, so some officials and news outlets are calling for the person who set off the alarm to be fired while Lichö hosts Stephen Colbert
即将到达夏威夷，立即寻求庇护。这不是演习。几分钟内，官员们就知道这是一个虚假警报，并开始进行损害控制，但直到8点45分，也就是这一切开始半个多小时后，才发布了取消警报。好吧，所以一些官员和新闻媒体呼吁解雇那个拉响警报的人，而《深夜秀》主持人史蒂芬·科尔伯特
joked around about the opposite idea. The agency in question also announced that the employee in question was reassigned. No! You'll keep him in that job! He's the one person on the planet who will never ever make that mistake again! He knows! Design guru Don Norman, who we talked with about, bad door design, also thinks the focus
开玩笑地提出了相反的想法。有关机构还宣布，有关员工被重新分配。不！你要让他留在那个岗位上！他是地球上唯一一个永远不会再犯那个错误的人！他知道！设计大师唐·诺曼，我们曾和他讨论过糟糕的门设计，他也认为焦点
is too much on the person. His basic argument is that if it's that easy to screw up, there's a design problem to be fixed. And I think it's safe to say that we're here at Nyanan. P.I. are members of the Church of Don Norman. Amen. And really, there are a number of design issues here. It was really easy to make this mistake
过多地集中在人身上。他的基本论点是，如果这么容易搞砸，那就是一个需要修复的设计问题。而且我认为可以肯定地说，我们在这里的99%隐形是唐·诺曼教会的成员。阿门。确实，这里有许多设计问题。犯这个错误真的太容易了
and to send out the alert. It's also too hard to retract it or issue correction. And then there's this lack of detail in the message, like where to find shelter, or phone numbers or links to websites that might help people get updates or more information. So people panic and many, if you're in the worst, call loved ones to say goodbye, which is just tragic.
并且发出警报。撤回它或发布更正也太难了。而且消息中缺乏细节，比如在哪里寻找庇护所，或者电话号码或网站链接，这些可能有助于人们获得更新或更多信息。所以人们恐慌，许多人，如果你处于最坏的情况，会打电话给亲人告别，这简直是悲剧。
I mean, this is a very high-stakes design problem. A lot of solutions are being floated. Some have called for introducing more friction to the process to slow things down and help avoid accidents. And that can involve adding steps, limiting lists of nearly identical options like they have right now. In favor of more clearly differentiated buttons with different button sizes and colors, all with the goal of making the test initiation easier and more obvious than sending an actual alert. So, already they're facing some of these issues, like creating a path to send out a correction more quickly, and from here on out, a second step person also needs to confirm a given
我的意思是，这是一个风险极高的设计问题。许多解决方案正在被提出。一些人呼吁在流程中引入更多的摩擦力，以减慢速度并帮助避免事故。这可能涉及增加步骤，限制像他们现在这样几乎相同的选项列表。转而使用更清晰区分的按钮，具有不同的按钮大小和颜色，所有这些目标都是使测试启动比发送实际警报更容易和更明显。所以，他们已经面临其中一些问题，比如创建一种更快速发送更正的路径，从现在开始，第二个人也需要确认给定的
selection. But some of these HACY solutions, I think just focus too much on human error or retracting the alerts after the fact and not really taking the design problem on head on. That's totally true. The process really has to be redesigned from start to finish. And some of these changes are in the works like having longer messages that also have emergency links
选择。但我认为其中一些HACY（黑客式）解决方案只是过多地关注人为错误或事后撤回警报，并没有真正正面解决设计问题。这完全正确。这个过程确实需要从头到尾重新设计。其中一些变化正在进行中，比如拥有更长的消息，这些消息也包含紧急链接
and numbers, even then though, they need to actually test the system more often so that people are familiar with it and know how to react. During this accidental alert it was discovered too that a number of emergency sirens played the wrong tune or just failed entirely. So it failed both as a false alarm and as an actual alarm. That's so very upsetting. Yeah it was reported that only 7% failed to signal what ended up being a false alarm, but that still seems just unnecessarily high. Yeah, but I think we can all agree that we need to lay off the poor sucker who pushed the
和号码，即使那样，他们也需要更频繁地测试系统，以便人们熟悉它并知道如何反应。在这次意外警报期间，还发现许多紧急警报器播放了错误的曲调或完全失效。所以它作为虚假警报和实际警报都失败了。这太令人不安了。是的，据报道只有7%的人未能发出最终被证明是虚假警报的信号，但这似乎仍然不必要地高。是的，但我认为我们都可以同意，我们需要放过那个按下
wrong button. Oh, definitely. That guy, I just hope his name never comes out. Oh, me too. Me too. All right, thank you, Kurt. Thanks. If you want to geek out even more about aarm Design, be sure to check out the mini-stories
错误按钮的可怜虫。哦，当然。那个人，我只希望他的名字永远不要被曝光。哦，我也是。我也是。好的，谢谢你，库尔特。谢谢。如果你想更多地了解警报设计，一定要看看上周的迷你故事
4 episode from last week. It's a fun one. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mix-intech production by Sheree Fusif, music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is the senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Choffman, Terran Masa, and me, Roman Mars.
4集。那很有趣。《99%隐形》本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，谢丽·福西夫进行混音技术制作，肖恩·里尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·乔夫曼、泰兰·马萨和我，罗曼·马尔斯。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. We are supported by the Night Foundation and listener donors who pitch in whatever they can to keep us making the best audio in the world. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。我们得到了奈特基金会和听众捐赠者的支持，他们尽其所能帮助我们制作世界上最好的音频。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@节目99PI org，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。
But if you think, I need more 99PI in my life. We have all the old episodes available and new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful website. It's 99pi.org. Radio tapio. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你认为，我的生活中需要更多的99PI。我们在我们美丽的网站上提供了所有旧剧集，每隔几天就有关于设计的新文章。网址是99pi.org。RadioTopia。你还没有这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。